foreign
good afternoon y'all let's talk about
blending reality and Imagination
but first let's take a step back in time
to 2001. as 11 year old in India I
became obsessed with computer graphics
and visual effects
of course at that age it meant making
cheesy videos kinda like this
but therein started a foundational theme
in my life the quest to blend reality
and Imagination and that Quest has
stayed with me and permeated across my
decade-long career in Tech working as a
product manager at companies like Google
and as a content creator on platforms
like YouTube and tick tock
I said today let's deconstruct this
quest to blend reality and Imagination
and explore how it's getting
supercharged buzzword alert by
artificial intelligence
let's start with the reality bit
you probably heard about photogrammetry
it's the Art and Science of measuring
stuff in the real world using photos and
other sensors what required massive data
centers and teams of experts in the
2000s became increasingly democratized
by the 2010s then of course machine
learning came along and took things to a
whole new level with techniques like
neural Radiance fields or Nerfs what
you're seeing here is an AI model
creating a Ground Up volumetric 3D
representation using 2D images alone
but unlike older techniques for reality
capture Nerfs do a really good job of
encapsulating the sheer complexity and
Nuance of reality the vibe if you will
12 months later you can do all of this
stuff using the iPhone in your pocket
using apps like Luma it's like 3D
screenshots for the real world capture
anything once and reframe it infinitely
in post-production so you can start
building that collection of spaces
places and objects that you truly care
about and conjure them up in your future
creations
so that's the reality bit as nurses were
popping off last year the AI summer was
also in full effect with mid-journey
Dolly too stable diffusion all hitting
the market around the same time
but what I fell in love with was in
painting this technique allows you to
take existing imagery and augment it
with whatever you like and the results
are photorealistically fantastic it blew
my mind because stuff that would have
taken me like three hours in classical
workflows I could pull off in just three
minutes
but I wanted more enter control net a
game-changing technique by Stanford
researchers that allows you to use
various input conditions to guide and
control the AI image generation process
so in my case I could take the depth
information and the texture detail for
my 3D scans and use it to literally
reskin reality
now this isn't just cool video there's a
lot of useful use cases too for example
in this case I'm taking a 3D scan of my
parents drawing room as my mother likes
to call it and re-skinning it to
different styles of Indian decor and
doing so while respecting the spatial
context and the layout of the Interior
Space
if you squint I'm sure you can see how
this is going to transform architecture
and interior design forever
you could take that 2016 scan of a
Buddha statue and reskin it to be
gloriously golden while pulling off
these impossible camera moves you just
couldn't do any other way
or you could take that vacation footage
from your trip to Tokyo and bring these
cherry blossoms to life in a whole new
way
and let me tell you cherry blossoms look
really good during the day but they look
even better at night
oh my God they sure are glowing it's
almost like this dreamlike quality where
you can use AI to accentuate the best
aspects of the real world
natural landscapes look just as
beautiful like this waterfall that could
be on another planet but of course you
could go over the hills and far away to
the French Alps From Another Dimension
but it's not just static scenes you can
do this stuff with video too
I can't wait till this technology is
running at 30 frames per second because
it's going to transform augmented
reality in 3D rendering I mean how soon
until we're channel surfing realities
layered on top of the real world
of course just like reality capture got
democratized all these tools from last
year are getting even easier so instead
of me spending hours weaving together a
bunch of different tools tools like
runaway and kyber let you do exactly the
same stuff with just a couple clicks
want to go from day to night no problemo
want to get that retro 90s aesthetic
from Full House you can do that too
but it goes beyond reality capture
companies like Wonder Dynamics are
turning video into this Immaculate form
of performance capture so you can embody
Fantastical creatures using the phone
into your pocket this is stuff that
James Cameron only dreamed about in the
2000s and now you could do it with your
iPhone that's absolutely wild to me
so when I look back at the past two
decades and this ill-tailored tapestry
of tools that I've had to learn I feel a
sense of optimism for what lays ahead
for the next generation of creators
the 11 year olds of today don't have to
worry about all of that crap all they
need to do is have a creative vision and
a knack for working in concert with
these AI models these AI models that are
truly a distillation of human knowledge
and creativity and that's a future I'm
excited about a future where you can
blend reality and Imagination with your
trusty AI co-pilot thank you very much
[Applause]